[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of severance episode 6 hide and seek
this was again directed by ifa mcardle
and written by amanda overton so this
episode has a lot of moving pieces going
on we get a lot of new information and
it really develops harmony here as this
obsessive follower of the values of keir
and lumen and we see that in this first
scene in the episode she's got these
dolls on a bed that look like they're
former ceos of lumen one definitely
being here and that she wears this
necklace of a chip which could be a
former lumen ceo but i'm thinking it's
probably her mother's because in the
lumen shrine we see this tube and it's
labeled charlotte cobell and date of
birth 1944. so there is another layer
here to the cobell family tree and we
also see that there's a picture of her
at the myrtle egan school for girls and
we know it's her because there's also a
certificate of graduation from that
school for harmony cobell and in this
lumen shrine we see picture of keir a
ticket to kier naval and this creepy
jester bust which was just strange so we
don't know what's going on there and
she's saying this line tammy and the
tempur's four which we learned about an
earlier episode so we're seeing how
intensely
she is in this belief system this cult
vibes we're getting of lumen with
harmony and like i said in my previous
review that she's clearly being set up
to really just be this big big bad it's
not that she's rebelling against the
company in a bad way she's making it her
own way so she also gets a call here
from greener that it is ragabi who
reintegrated pd and mess with his chip
who will me at the end of the episode
who mark runs into which we'll get to
but at lumen here we'll see that bert
shows irv this room of plants that he
found right it's like their love it's
kind of symbolizing his life this room
is full of life that's what's giving
them life in this dreary workplace but
you know it's interesting that irv is
still resistant to it because of the
handbook and romantic fraternization and
bert's kind of you know saying like you
know kissing isn't bad though we could
kiss but irv's not ready for this yet he
is just paranoid about the rule book and
i don't know there's a part of me that
still thinks maybe bert is a test for
irv and that bert might not be as
trustworthy as he looks just because
christopher walken's playing him i have
a feeling there's more to him than just
being someone that could be an alliance
to mark and their team in general i
think that there could be tests still
here of loyalty and speaking of
fraternization you know we see dylan
calls out mark here for that with helly
this is like a big moment where there's
some serious flirting going on between
the two i actually didn't want them to
go down this route though i thought it
was kind of refreshing that there wasn't
kind of a love story developing between
the two of them so people have been
calling that i didn't really want to go
that way just a personal preference
because i think it's actually more
interesting keeping that separate from
this story of these characters but so be
it but it's clearly going that route now
and will be interesting to see how it
affects mark and his decisions in lumen
okay so it's crazy as we see devin now
sees gabby who was the pregnant woman
from last episode she saw at the cabin
but she sees her outside this park and
the baby has a different name than the
name she said she was going to name it
where she says she's going to name it
william but now it's bradley so this
confuses devon as it confuses the
audience and she meets her husband
angelo so angelo who she's going to look
into later on in the computer and do a
little investigative work sees that he's
a state senator right and there's a lot
of stuff i caught with that scene which
i actually want to get into now so in
that article she's reading it says he's
a staunch supporter of legalized
severance right and then says under
picture of him posing with his wife and
their two kids in that picture is that
this is for cure life magazine the
picture and that they're in their
hometown of kier which is just showing
so much about this power of kier and
that there's a town named after him
there's a magazine named after him and
the next article shows that he was a big
advocate for companies like lumen to be
able to use severance so this all makes
me think obviously he's going to be a
big villain character the husband but
that he is up to no good with the
process of severance and that i think
his wife is severed and that there's two
versions of her going on where she's
severed where she's not even remembering
who she's having maybe the baby with or
what the name of the baby is this is two
life she's seeing and that's why you see
that guy running out of the cabin last
episode that clearly wasn't her husband
who she was with and saying she was
named a different name so maybe they've
severed her into two different
relationships which is insane so that's
definitely my theory for that so it's
seeing severed in a non-work way which
was really shown in this episode and the
power they have with severing people
beyond the building which happens with
dylan which we're going to get to so
mark will find out from harmony that
miss casey was punished really for his
actions and she's been sent to the break
room which mark hates he always feels
guilt for that and miss casey also
learns a part-timer which is interesting
that they even have part-timers at lumen
and you know she's like who won't you go
to the break room for sniffing around
other departments while your department
falls under quota but this is when he
asked her what do we actually do here
she snaps you like we serve here you
child and until you get that through
your mildewed little brain get your
little ass back to your desk until you
are told to move this whole scene was
very strange and i think it was
purposely that way and it's kind of
falling to the scene we'll see many
lines referencing being childs here
treated like children and someone had
mentioned one of my comments that the
baby goats from last episode are
actually you know called kids so it's
this theme going on clearly about them
being treated like children and there's
probably more to that and theories about
what they really are and i'm also
thinking because it's such a strange
scene how she yells at him and then how
he kind of reacts and repeats what she
says saying no
inter-departmental visits to irv that
maybe there is something with a severing
procedure that there's a way they can
communicate to the person who's severed
kind of brainwash them that just by
being strict with them and that they
kind of repeat those behaviors but it's
not working as well to mark because he
clearly rebels right away and maybe this
is why she asked for more maintenance to
the building maybe there's going to be
stricter technology on their severance
when they go down that elevator that's a
theory i got going too and now this
episode when he's reading from the book
of rick and right about camaraderie and
we're seeing that camaraderie happen
between departments but also mark now
standing up for these four people in his
department going against harmony and
going to omd and it's really working
well this book for rick and again to
mark and i love there was a commenter on
one of my videos saying that it's so
fascinating how really marx audi would
not read this book by rick and he would
never follow someone like rick and but
it's just crazy that
it's like his saving grace for his innie
which is really cool the juxtaposition
there so you can get the theories going
of why o and d is making watering cans
here and that they said last week they
were making hatchets but we see mark
speaking like a true leader here again
all that subconscious stuff coming
through rickon's book but he's talking
about finding out what the hell is going
on here and that lumen philosophy is
about illumination then why are we still
down here working in the dark again i
love when the show is having themes just
about corporate we can kind of all
relate to this corporate lifestyle and
feeling like the people on the bottom
work the hardest don't even know what
they're planning up top that we're kind
of kept in the dark so that really spoke
to me as well and he's being smart here
mark by using here's philosophy to get
people on board like that's how you
convince brainwashed people to go
against how their company is working
like wait this isn't even the value of
the company to be kept in the dark it's
calling out the hypocrisy and other
theories we can get going is now dylan
finds these cards that show like
physical movements and again it kind of
leads that cloning theory i was talking
about and like what is really going on
here why do we even see pictures like
this of training how to move and this is
when milchik shows up and he'll see
later on the cameras that dylan took one
of these cards which will lead to that
scene that's really important which
we're going to get to but i wanted to
point out when mark and all of them are
leaving with mr milchik he's like we're
not children mr milchik we didn't do
anything wrong again going to this theme
about them being treated like children
and harmony's singing this kier song
which is just creepy and mark is being
punished by being sent to the break room
but there's a little smirk on his face
now this is different than the mark who
would have been horrified and scared and
now he's kind of happy and not
remorseful and that yeah that they're
you know sticking it to them and i love
the cut here with the editing of mark's
hand on that break room door and then to
his audi mark on a date with alexa and
he's got the marks on his hands that are
bruised from the break room and we see
more and more how lexa is good for marx
audi to help him get over his wife and
that she's a perfect match for him
because she even lets him talk about
gemma in a healthy way so again this is
someone he the more he's with the more
it's going to clear up his mind to think
about what he needs to be thinking about
with someone like ragabi now we see
harmony as miss selvik is one of the
people who's a candidate to be the nanny
for devon's baby which is just
horrifying and it seems like she's got
to be singing a cure lullaby right to
the baby to put it to sleep but this is
what she'll say later on is research for
her so she's interested in mark's sister
now which is bad and what's going on
with this baby and if they're catching
on as well because devon now knows this
important figure in the senator now the
huge scene that reveals a lot of stuff
is that mild chick wakes dylan up at his
home showing us you can be severed by
just the switch here on and off not just
by the elevator triggering it that the
company has the power to do this from a
switch which is crazy and this really is
just gonna make you have all these
theories about what lumens really up to
and just mind control and that if you
can control people like this you can do
so much and it's huge now though that we
see dylan's outside work for a little
bit that he has a kid and that he saw
his kid that his you know work he
doesn't even know he has a child so
seeing that is huge and let me tell you
at this point in the review i'm dripping
sweat in this wig now
for my angle reviewing this episode
where it started to dip for me was when
mark is going with alexa to june's rock
band concert right and they're playing
this anti-lumen theme which was very
headache inducing i get there was
supposed to be humor to this but this
was torturous to watch honestly or
listen to i guess and he's like i think
your dad would have liked it and she's
you know resistant to this still doesn't
trust him but i don't even know if he
really needed this scene that much i
mean it's there to kind of get alexa
into this story with mark about petey
and remind him about petey and what's
going on but we kind of already got this
from the funeral so i don't know how
necessary it was but either way it
slowed up the episode a lot it just
wasn't great but then mark finally
finally thinks about pd collapsing again
and goes to grab this never-ending
ringing phone that we learned is ragabi
but again what frustrates me i saw
people complaining about this which i
agree with about how much this phone's
ringing how the phone hasn't died yet
but even so how does he have this phone
off all day and she was still calling
and not quitting even though she
probably would have went right to
voicemail with pd's phone so the chance
of her still calling the phone right
when he puts the phone back on was
insane that was like okay you're really
asking me to suspend my disbelief here
on that you got to make it make a little
more sense and not just totally cheat
but mark meets ragabi and now grainer is
also on their tail so that's gonna be
interesting and i think they're really
gonna have to confront greiner here and
that he might not make it much longer in
this show but this was actually you know
we learn a lot but there's a it was the
weakest episode to me of the show yet
i'm gonna give this one 8.3 where a lot
of them have been putting in the nine
range
and why i give it a lower score is i
really feel like last week it started
dip a bit in quality in the sense of
it's not hooking you as much here like i
don't feel on the edge of my seat these
last two episodes and i think the first
four episodes really had you gripped and
engaged and it wasn't letting go where i
feel like these last two do have moments
where it feels a little bit filled out
and it's annoying because the episodes
are also shorter and somehow they feel a
little more stretched out so you feel
the stretch of the story coming and
again it just doesn't feel as tight or
it just feels like you can zone out a
little more here so i think it's
actually too slow of a pace especially
in this episode so i'm giving this one
8.3 and i don't think that's something
that will continue the whole season i
think you know we're hitting that middle
patch of a season that just slows down
and feels a little stretched which is
unfortunate it's never going to be
perfect but definitely my least favorite
episode of the season i hope things pick
up next week it looks like it's a longer
run time and again we've learned a lot
more to move some pieces together but
again really if you look at the last two
episodes a lot of it was just like okay
it's formed to show this you know
teaming up and unionizing between
departments but now this episode's you
know really more form to give the reveal
of who was on that phone of pd's and
mark to find out and for us to find out
as well but not much else so yes i'm
giving this 8.3 but let me know what you
thought if you loved it if you didn't
like it i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment and try to respond as
many as i can please make sure to
subscribe one of my reviews of severance
and follow me at steven's show on
twitter instagram tic tac for more of me
and i'll see you next time